hello everyone and welcome back to the
match that simply keeps on giving it is
magnus carlsen versus han smoke and iman
and this is the third game of their
match if you are just joining in the
match uh the match started by niman
winning a brilliant brilliant game
against magnus with the black pieces and
then magnus retaliated with a brilliancy
of his own with the black pieces
although niemann's brilliance was more
of a middle game brilliant whereas
magnus's brilliancy was more of an
endgame brilliancy and now you think
okay the match will probably quiet down
a little bit it's going to be
you know a nice uh nice quiet game uh
not really uh here magnus with the white
pieces opens with pawn to a3 this is the
so-called anderson opening and for those
of you who have been following the
channel and have been through all of the
videos or at least those near the end of
the morphe saga uh have probably seen
seen this as it was played in the match
uh between uh paul charles morphe and
adult anderson uh the famous one in the
in paris in 1858 uh and um
it was uh it was a brilliant brilliant
attempt by anderson to throw morphy of
guard and he was successful at it he
defeated morphy and interestingly morphy
replied with e5 to this move but uh here
instead of e5 we have pawn to d5 now
it's uh
it's a very interesting uh idea uh
playing something that
differently than morphe because mostly
when you have a position you know morphe
played then you play with morphe play
that's common sense because morphe is
the strongest uh but morphe lost this
game so maybe uh we could you know play
play something else here and that's why
niemann goes pawn to d5
we have d4 by magnus knight to f6 knight
to f3 and bishop to f5 now we have pawn
to c4
c6 and now there are some games for c
capture sunday five was played on also
queen b3 putting pressure on d5 and b7
was played but here magnus plays knight
to c3 and it is now already as of move
five that we have a completely new game
so here pawn to e6 the bishop is out of
the cage so we might as well close the
structure and not knight the h4 just a
very very
uh standard idea we're gonna eliminate
this bish we attack it with the knight
uh and even already spent a few moves uh
uh you know just setting up this bishop
so it would be positioned properly so we
might as well trade our knight for it so
bishop g4 and not interested in just
going bishop g6 right away and allowing
magnus to capture it the ship to g4 we
have pawn to f3 and now bishop to h5 we
have c characters on d5 c captures and
now just g3
so magnus playing uh some very very
weird chess here knight to c6 and not
knight back to g2 we have queen to b6
now uh putting pressure on that d4 pawn
and magnus simply defends pawn to e3
bishop to d6 and now knight to f4
putting pressure on the bishop here and
now you could just capture bishop
captures an f4 and even though this is
good for black uh it's hard to say uh
what uh magnus had in mind here it's not
like uh neiman
had this over the board or did any
serious work how to play against a3 and
if you're wondering why magnus decided
to play against a3 was it maybe to just
uh yeah completely confused nemo did he
did some uh serious work on a3 did he
just want to assert his dominance
probably a mixture of all of those uh
things
and even though this is good for black
you know it's a completely wild position
uh maybe maybe you don't want to play
this against magnus so bishop back to g6
knight captures h captures and now king
to f2 by magnus now he's going to play
king to g2 and what uh what is even
happening here we have ponte he's six
now king to g2
uh and you can see that the tine is such
that one of the one of the commentators
of the official uh
team uh said that it's uh
basically playing in the spirit of bong
cloud and here yes the king is uh uh in
in a very difficult spot uh but this
can't be good for white but again uh
this brings me over to something anish
geary said uh at some point i i think it
was like maybe a month ago uh he said
that um yes you have these uh very
strong engines and they are giving all
sorts of evaluations that black is
better
minus
0.5 or white is better plus one and a
half or black is completely winning plus
plus three uh yeah he said it very well
uh
you're either winning or you're not
you're either winning or it's a draw
okay or the other side is winning but
let's say one player is better so you're
either winning or uh it's a draw it
doesn't matter what the evaluations say
even if it's like a plus two and a half
uh it's still either a draw or you're
winning so uh you know it's uh
it's a really weird way of looking at
things but um
it definitely makes a good point so here
even though the engine prefers black it
doesn't really mean anything so here we
have castles nieman says all right uh my
setup here is um
very strong and your king is just weird
i'm gonna bust open the position with e5
and you're gonna have a well just a
weird weird king's position so here
magnus plays g4 and neiman strikes right
away with e5 we have pawn to g5
attacking the knight but he captures on
d4 not scared of
magnus's advancement e captures on d4
and not knight to h5 we have knight
captures on d5 attacking neiman's queen
here and now queen captures on d4 and
this is a weird decision by niemann
going for a queen trade against magnus
here you go back and now you have this
position where magnus has a king on g2
and
still the
board is full of pieces uh so it
definitely makes sense um
uh to do this but he played queen
captures on d4 and now magnus very very
happily traded queens queen captures
knight captures and now rook to b1 as
knight to b3 could be very annoying so
rugby one preparing b4 and now rook f2d8
uh putting the rook in front of the
knight here uh but just the bush of the
d3 uh there are no good discoveries uh
because there's always this nasty knight
to b6 move for example the bishop
captures an h2 hoping that you can win
the knight just knight b6 now the rook
is hanging and also your bishop is
hanging so after bishop to d3 rook 8 to
c8 and now we have rook to d1 by magnus
and look at this spectacular party
happening on the d file
i don't know if we've ever had like uh
six pieces on on one file uh pretty sure
we've had five i'm not sure about six so
okay knight the e6 and bishop to e4
magnus improving the position of his
bishop uh king to f8 and now bishop to
d2 at some point the bishop might assume
this diagonal uh we have knight h to f4
with check and now comes knight captures
on f4 knight captures an f4 with check
and magnus not eager to give up the
bishop pair goes king to f1 we have b6
as the pawn on b7 is hanging but now
magnus just plays bishop to b7 attacks
the rook and now will win the a6 spawn
so rogue b8 bishop captures an a6 and
not knight to e6
uh and now neiman has to again uh face
the very very sad reality of uh being in
an end game against magnus cross and
being down a pawn so bishop to c4 and
not knight to d4 the knight is very
active so even though magnus has the
bishop paired the knight is a very very
strong piece here so king g2 defending
the pawn here and now rook beat the c8
putting pressure on the bishop
we have bishop to a6 now attacking the
rook and rook the c7 uh we have bishop
to c3 this is very useful as we control
this diagonal and also uh you don't have
to worry about any future infiltrating
moves with the rook like rook the c2 so
knight back to e6 now putting pressure
on the g5 pawn and now we have pawn to
a4 yeah very very very good stuff uh the
point is if rook if knight captures um
on g5 magnus had in mind this rook
and d6 maneuver and now after rook
captures on d6 you can just play bishop
to b4 and you're going to win the
exchange back so here after
a4 we have kinked the e7 but not just
pawn to h4 magnus defense's g5 pawn we
have knight f4 knight f4 check king f2
and not knight back to e6 just harassing
crosston's king uh bishop to b5 and now
rook to h8 putting pressure on the pawn
here so rook to h1 a bit of a passive
move for the white rook but uh the black
rook is also passive so it's cool uh
bishop to c5 with check came to g3 and
not bishop back to d6 with king back to
g2 by magnus none again knight to f4
with check king f2 bishop the c5 and now
king to g3
and now the problem is uh you can't
continue with bishop to d6 even though
you would very much like to as now it
seems like you're threatening all sorts
of discoveries but just rook beat the e1
check and you don't have a move if you
go to f8 then rook to e8 is checkmate
and if you go back knight to e6 open up
a discovery now we just play f4 and uh
not a worry in the world for you uh even
though you can play bishop characters on
f4 with check after king to g4 it's
still a much much better or rather a
winning position for white so no no real
worries here if you go back bishop to d6
bishop captures and g7 then bishop comes
to f6 and it's very very ugly for black
look at those bishops slicing all over
the place so instead after king to g3
knight back to
e6 once again and now rook beat the e1
uh pinning this knight we have bishop to
d6 check and now king back to g2 you
could also play f4 but magnus
waits with the pawn uh in game one
against hans uh he pushed upon and then
of course he could never unpush it so
yeah he's gonna wait with it pawn to f6
now comes rook to e4 preparing to double
up on the e file as now the f6 move has
weakened the knight from the f5 now
comes rook to c4 offering a trade of
rooks uh knights the f4 with check king
to f2 and now bishop to c5 with check
and magnus says i've had it with your
knight f4 check and bishop c5 check
let's go for it rook captures and c5
point being that if you capture with the
pawn which seems like a good idea then
bishop captures and g7 and there's
always this bishop to f6 move uh that
just makes it impossible for black to do
anything with this rook for example if
rook to a8 if you go here then of course
we just deliver a check king has to go
somewhere and then bishop e5 will attack
the knight the rook the rook on b8 uh
and if you go for the rook to aid a
still bishop f6 check and whatever you
play we're just gonna go for a double
attack here
uh so after rook captures on c5 uh rook
captures on c5 by neman and now just
bishop the b4 we're gonna win the
material back knight to e6 and now of
course bishop captures on c5 knight
captures and now pawn to b4 meaning that
a5 is coming and of course magnus will
create a pass pawn so 96 uh bishop to c
for now magnus just showing that he
knows that the rook end game is winning
and he really wants to trade this bishop
for night now so neiman dick
decides not to allow this and rook to e1
check king d6 rook to d1 now threatening
to pick up the knight king e5 and now
pawn to f4 with check trying to give up
a pawn to win the knight so king e4 and
now just bishop back to f1
preparing to push the a5 pawn create a
passer and then win the game so king
back to d5 uh the king cannot really
cross uh over to help out with the
defense of the queen side as the knight
here would just be captured so a5b
not b4 a b5 but rather b captures on a5
b captures on a5 and now rook to b8 uh
we have pawn to a6 advancing the pawn
king to c5 and now just rook to c1 with
check king d6 and now king to e3
attacking the knight here knight to c6
and now rook to c3 not allowing any
sneaky rook to be three checks and here
again it's not possible for the black
king to help out uh with the defense uh
against this past a pawn uh because if
you go king to c7 then the very simple
bishop g2 just ends the game on the spot
uh of course white is now threatening to
win the night and if you defend it white
very happily trades or arrow you can
even push a7 it doesn't really matter
the knight can't go anywhere if king b7
we now trade rook captures throw
captures bishop captures and now you
cannot capture the bishop because the
white promotes the pawn to a queen so
you have to capture the pawn and now you
have a bishop against no pieces of
course completely winning for magnus so
after rook to c3 we have knight to a7 uh
and now bishop the c4 we have rooked the
e8 with check king to f3 and now rook
the e7 trying to set up a blockade here
as you do have a light square bishop so
maybe the pawn cannot cross a dark
square
but there are other problems for you to
worry about rook to e3
of course a trade of rooks is winning
for magnus so rook to d7 and now rook to
d3 with check king c7 uh and now magnus
shows why it is winning rook captures
king captures and now bishop to f7 these
spawns are on light squares you attack
the base of the pawn chain and there is
no defending this for black so king c6
bishop captures and g6 was played king
to b6 now comes pawn to h5 knight to c6
and now just h6 creating a pass pawn g
captures g captures and he was in this
position on move 72 that hans mocha
neman resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here magnus will
just play ponte h7 pawn to h8 bring a
queen into the game and of course that's
it if you try something like knight to
e7 uh
so if h7 then we can capture the bishop
and guard the dh8 square just bishop f7
guards both the g6 and this so there's
really nothing to worry about now you
can escort your pawn freely up the board
and that's it so of course nima knows
this after night
after g captures on h6 he resigned the
game and the magnus takes uh
a lead in the match even though he lost
the first game so now he wins game two
he wins game three by playing a3 the uh
out of anderson's grand opening like i
said that was used in the legendary
match against paul morphy so truly truly
incredible stuff and for those of you
who are interested i could check as the
game four is um still being played so i
could check how game four ended all
right i know how the game four ended uh
so if you guys are interested how the
match ended i will tell you now if
you're not interested you know don't
listen uh magnus has also won game four
with the black pieces so final result is
three to one neiman starts by winning
game one and then magnus wins three
games in a row and again in game four
magnus played the g6 so it was uh it was
just brutal
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it really really impressive
stuff by magnus um
uh not uh you know uh uh allowing niman
any chances there were some chances but
like like anishigiri said uh you're
either winning or you're not if you're
not then your opponent can have a great
great game regardless of what the engine
says uh so you know always keep that in
mind uh don't just listen to the engine
uh i would like to thank alex varsilio
francis air ricky emini excellent
subscriber and brandon ward for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing uh the coverage of
the ftx crypto cup uh until it finishes
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day